[Music]
[Applause]
this is the hyacinth macaw it's big it's
bright and it's vulnerable to lots of
threats the largest parrot by length in
the world it can grow up to 40 inches
their feathers are a beautiful striking
blue unfortunately their good looks have
made them highly desirable in the
illegal pet trade fetching upwards of
10,000 dollars hyacinths are native to
Central and South America primarily in
the scrublands at the outskirts of the
rainforest it is an affectionate bird
but its powerful beak carries over 200
pounds of pressure per square inch
strong enough to crack a coconut their
diet in the wild consists mostly of nuts
from native palms beyond being a hot
commodity in the pet trade hyacinths are
watching their habitats get converted to
farmland leaving them less and less
space to live this is the hyacinth macaw
[Music]
this is indigo real indigo jeans they're
died from a chemical but real indigo
straight from the plant has its roots in
samurai culture and it's highly prized
in Japan yep this story is all about the
real color blue but it's not as dull as
it sounds
[Music]
Tokushima Japan is located in the
southwest of the country
and for centuries it has been known for
its indigo due to the yoshinogawa River
which flows underground warming the soil
indigo started gaining popularity in the
early 1600s and was commonly used by
samurais so do are you doing the silikal
tunnel that you thought you Illuminati
but it's got a yo-yo kisser
this is Osama knee he's a sixth
generation indigo plant grower totally
stunning is name is alamelu so you know
minutes with the most biggest of them
all Kiki's demo can I go to say agua
real indigo was also used for
firefighters clothing because it's
flame-retardant up to 1500 degrees
Fahrenheit
to produce indigo ink the leaves must be
harvested and then dried in the Sun and
flipped repeatedly with a broom until
they turn a navy he'll be eating it got
a physical to send us there because of
this Osamu is one of the last five in
new grow growers in the region the
practice is time-consuming and
labor-intensive so former growers have
turned to cheaper chemical alternatives
but the thing is with real indigo the
color you can achieve is unparalleled
this is Toshi haru furusho he's a fabric
tire yaya submitted Talkies even given
about same day some attention when i was
taken over by he is able to pull out an
incredible range of blues from the
natural ink from a nearly black blue
they called nano arrow to deep ocean
Hughes called catchy arrow achieving
these colors though is not easy
I don't know need Toco Toco his
commitment to his craft can be seen in
his hands his nails are eternally
stained blue from nearly 50 years of
working with the die tomorrow why was da
meet I wonder what do you know this man
I know Sam oh he's not hanging his trial
yet up either yeah buddy Pocoyo
Suzuka think OTO who know Iman okay no I
saw no kimochi is good you know yes hi
bye number 2 good luck to you Shekar
enough didn't
[Music]
with the lifespan able to reach as old
as 69 these iguanas can live as long as
humans this is the Grand Cayman blue
iguana
found only in Grand Cayman the largest
and westernmost of the Cayman Islands
their blue skin becomes more prominent
when establishing territory when other
iguanas are nearby males turn especially
bright blue during breeding season but
their blue skin isn't their only
defining feature they have striking red
eyes and excellent vision which enables
them to notice shapes and movement at
long distances listed as endangered due
to human activity habitat loss and being
preyed upon by free roaming predators
such as dogs cats and rats these
beautiful blue lizards face an uphill
battle against extinction this is the
Grand Cayman blue iguana
[Music]
[Music]
remember Finding Nemo the movie that
introduced us to clownfish dory the
absent-minded sidekick now has her own
movie but marine conservationists
they're not excited they're actually
kind of worried this right here is a
blue tang the real-life dory they only
live on coral reefs in the South Pacific
but before we get to her story let's
talk about Nemo the clownfish when
Finding Nemo came out well okay I'll let
Karen tell you I'm Karen Burke da Silva
I'm a marine biologist and a
conservation biologists here at Flinders
University of South Australia so what
happened with Finding Nemo after the
release of Finding Nemo we found that
there was quite a big increase in the
number of people that wanted a clownfish
as a pet with the increase in demand it
did have an increase in captive breeding
but it also meant that more fish were
being taken from the wild and in fact
some places there's been so much over
collecting that clownfish have gone
locally extinct
oh so captive breeding seems like the
way to go back to Dory the blue tang if
her movie has the same effect as Nemo's
moviegoers are sure to want to buy a
blue tang of their own but there's a
problem and you are my name is Matt de
Maggio I'm a assistant professor at the
University of Florida truffle
aquaculture laboratory ok Matt so what's
the problem
clownfish are relatively easy to raise
in captivity but up until now no one has
raised blue tags in captivity blue tang
larvae are inherently difficult to raise
they have a very small mouth when they
hatch out so the food particles that we
have to offer them are much smaller and
much more difficult to raise the best
success we've had to date is using a Zoe
plankton called a copepod the copepods
that we grow here only eat live
microalgae so you not have to grow live
microalgae
feed to the copepods basically raising
blue tank so far is really really hard
which means a hundred percent of blue
tang are currently being taken from the
wild for the aquarium trade most
collectors in Australia will use very
careful collecting measures in other
parts of the world Southeast Asia they
are using cyanide still to collect
aquarium fish that's not good but
there's hope Matt and his team are
working hard to breathe blue tangs
successfully there's only one other tank
species the yellow tang that's ever been
raised in captivity before we're hoping
that the blue tang will be the second
alright so until they do when little
Johnny says he wants a Dory
perhaps the better choice for now at
least is to stick to the blue betta or a
goldfish
[Music]
[Music]
what may look like a beautiful green
oasis is actually the top of an active
volcano
[Music]
located in Java Indonesia is the
collagen volcano at its top sits a
highly acidic crater lake the water is
90 degrees Fahrenheit and appears bluish
green no species live in or around the
water as the conditions are too harsh
for nature to survive at night a rare
phenomenon can be seen unlike any other
volcano in the world
collagen emits what appears to be bright
blue flames this blue glow is not caused
by lava but instead from a combustion of
sulfuric acids once the gas is cool a
bright yellow sulphur forms which is
mined and sold miners use steel bars to
break off portions of the sulfur and
carry up to 200 pounds back down the
volcano the emitted gases are toxic if
inhaled making this strenuous work
incredibly dangerous
while this unique volcano may be home to
one of the world's most grueling jobs it
is also a sight worth seeing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this butterfly was once thought to be
extinct though rediscovered it remains
one of the world's rarest and most
elusive butterflies this is the palos
verdes blue butterfly this butterfly is
as elusive as it is beautiful and the
brilliance of its blue wings are only
visible when it opens them the wings are
distinctive with their brilliant silvery
blue color the butterfly was thought to
be extinct in the 1980s when it seemed
to disappear without a trace it wasn't
until the 1990s that this visually
striking butterfly was spotted again
biologists were surprised and delighted
in its existence and a breeding program
was begun to build up the species though
captive breeding has helped bolster
numbers the population is still low
enough to remain on the endangered list
through careful nurturing and management
this small but mighty butterfly has a
fighting chance this is the palos verdes
blue butterfly
you